My memories are broken but i know i
brought these
mighty warriors here to defend our
reality
high above this strange land is where
we'll prepare to stand against him galactus
the devourer of worlds we
must remember who we are storm
iron man mystique
doctor doom
wolverine and i am groot
indeed our greatest war
begins here now we will explore this
land
regain our powers and reclaim our
memories
join us together we will defeat galactus
and save all reality
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new marvel avengers
secret war game trailer marvel is doing
a big crossover with fortnite i'll
explain what's going on
they actually just wrote a story for it
so they canonized fortnite
to the marvel movies because you got
that shout out during avengers end game
and now the characters themselves are
canon to the marvel 616 universe
they asked me to make a video about it
so many thanks to them for sponsoring
this i'll do a giveaway for copies of
the game too all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and let me know which
your favorite marvel character to play
with is
there's a whole lot of stuff going on in
this trailer obviously this does feel
like a big
marvel phase for marvel phase 5 secret
wars build up
because that's where we're headed in the
marvel movies but fortnite season 4
just launched this past week a couple
days ago so that's up and rolling now so
as part of the battle pass as part of
these achievements that you can unlock
there's a whole bunch of marvel
characters everybody
you have wolverine you have storm you
have all the x-men all the avengers
characters
and i believe some fantastic four
characters are coming to the game too i
think there's going to be an unlockable
silver surfer skin that you can get in
the game as well so if you're really
hyped up about silver surfer fantastic
four stuff happening during marvel phase
as well that'll all be happening in the
game the whole deal with the marvel
crossover story is that it actually
flows out of the cosmic thor comics so
like in the game you see thor is wearing
his cosmic thor outfit from the recent
comics
the marvel crossover story in the 616
marvel comic book universe is called the
nexus war story line it's written by
donnie cades who's been writing the
current thor storyline in the comics for
the past year or so
so it actually starts with a flashback
to thor being crowned king of asgard
and taking the throne at the beginning
of the new thor rebooted comic book
then galactus shows up half dead
crashing to asgard telling thor that the
next major galactic threat coming to
wipe them all out the entire universe
is called the black winter he says that
thor needs to become his new herald and
help him find
energy rich worlds to consume so that he
can power up
enough himself to defeat the black
winter so thor becomes the next herald
of galactus imbued with cosmic power
you call him cosmic thor he gets the
shiny new outfit
he's way more op than he was before and
they just start going around the
universe consuming these special energy
rich planets powering galactus up
this is where it sort of diverges from
the recent thor comic book story
so during this nexus war crossover while
they're flying around consuming these
planets
galactus detects a tear in the fabric of
reality between dimensions
giving off enormous amounts of energy
and because he's galactus he wants that
sweet sweet energy honey
thor tries to stop him from going all
super adhd
and keep him on task we need to stop the
black winter we need to save this
universe
so thor flies through the rift ahead of
galactus and winds up on the fortnite
island
meeting the characters from the fortnite
game so now they're basically saying
that fortnite is now canon to the 616
marvel comics it's just another universe
in the multiverse which is crazy
post all your noob master memes in the
comments
i thought he's back that kid on the tv
just called me a d*ckhead again noob
master
hopefully they'll pay off the noob
master joke in avengers 5 when ryan
reynolds deadpool crosses over and
reveal him
as new master from avengers end game but
as thor flies through into this world of
fortnite he immediately loses his
memories forgetting why he came there
but somehow remembers galactus is coming
so he starts fighting with the regular
fortnight characters because that's just
how thor says hello
then galactus shows up inside the world
of fortnite to consume that fortnite
planet
so thor's ravens who can now travel
between the dimensions seek out the
other major marvel x-men
fantastic four and avengers characters
that you see during the trailer
beckoning them to come to the fortnite
dimension and help thor stop galactus
so during this trailer when you see them
all being portaled away by the bifrost
that's with the rainbow bridges here
that just sucking them up into
nothingness is basically portaling them
to the world of fortnite to help stop
galactus
so when they call this big crossover
event with fortnite and marvel the nexus
war the nexus is just the space
bridging the marvel 616 universe with
the fortnite universe
i know a lot of you are also asking like
why is she hulk a character in the game
and not the incredible hulk bruce banner
a lot of this i think is just to build
synergy for the upcoming marvel phase
four projects that they have coming
so for instance they're getting ready to
introduce the she-hulk character during
marvel phase four they haven't said when
that
disney plus series is going to premiere
and they haven't announced who the
actress is that's going to player her is
but because the audience of fortnite is
very similar to the audience of people
going to see marvel movies they just
want to start to get people familiar
with some of those characters the fact
that they're featuring galactus so
heavily because galactus is just one of
the next big
galactic threats that they introduced in
the mcu avengers level threats for
something like avengers 5 or avengers 6
whatever those movies wind up being
that's kind of the whole reason for nick
fury going to the sword space station
in earth's orbit because the next big
avengers threats will come from outer
space
we also have x-men now in the mcu
because marvel got the right stole the
characters back so they just want to get
people
thinking big about x-men characters
again interacting with the other
avengers because that's what's going to
be happening during marvel phase 5 in
avengers 5.
still going to be a hot minute before we
see that next x-men solo film we'll see
the marvel fantastic four
rebooted film before we see the new
rebooted x-men film
in fact hugh jackman just posted a clip
of himself talking about doing a hulk vs
wolverine movie with mark ruffalo in
their new quote-unquote rivalry
i'll post it tomorrow because it's
actually pretty funny right now he
doesn't have any plans to actually come
back for a movie but he is hyping up
big hulk vs wolverine during marvel
phase 4 marvel phase 5.
even though we're not going to see the new
rebooted version of wolverine probably
at least till 2023 2024 at the earliest
and are you're all wondering about the
disney plus falcon and winter soldier in
one division episodes that are supposed
to premiere this year
they'll be setting up more wolverine
weapon 10 weapon x
stuff during the falcon and winter
soldier series is part of the super
soldier program the weapons plus program
spinning out of the incredible hulk and
the stuff that thunderbolt ross has been
doing the past couple of years
still really hoping for some thunderbolt
ross red hulk during marvel phase 4. i
also think we'll see some easter eggs
for that during the falcon and winter
soldier series but i don't know how long
it's going to be before they actually do
red hulk in the mcu just in terms of
bigger
secret wars movie stuff going on the
russo brothers actually
pitched that to marvel they said that
they still talk to marvel on a regular
basis
they still hang out with kevin feige and
the marvel producers all the time even
though they're busy making smaller films
right now they're just taking a break
from doing really big marvel films
the way they actually pitch their
version of avengers secret wars
is that it would actually be a multiple
film series way bigger than avengers
infinity war in avengers end game
there's another team of superheroes that
i've worked with before
computer bring me one of the x-men
which one good question so originally
avengers infinity war was actually going
to be a two-part film
like they had the title screen that said
avengers infinity war part 1 and
infinity war part 2. the only reason why
they changed the title to avengers end
game for part 2
is because the plot was just so
different from the plot of part one so
that it didn't feel like a part two it
felt like a completely different film
they said that right now their plan for
a secret wars movie would be to do it as
a multiple film series like three
four five different films just because
it's so big
there's no way you could do it in just
two movies let me know in the comments
though when do you actually think that
they'll get around to doing
secret wars do you think it's going to be
like five or six years or do you think
it's going to take them another 10 years
to get there
but if you didn't see the unfortunate
news chadwick boseman
black panther himself actually just
passed away
it was very very unfortunate very sudden
very surprising everyone is still
freaking out trying to process their
grief
you can click here for my memorial video
and to learn about that
and click here for all my other marvel
phase 4 trailer videos
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!
you